listen this is not a motivational video
but this is probably the most important
video you can watch during a time like
this while the market tank the way that
it has and everybody else is talking
about you know the dreams the Lambos the
Ferraris the watches the houses this is
the message you need to hear I can show
you my house I can show you my savings I
can show you all that stuff but I'm
telling you my life changed when I 27 28
years old at a quarter million dollars
in the bank and I was driving a Ford
Focus and everybody thought I was crazy
and I want to share this mindset with
you odds are you going to click off this
video because you want to go get
entertained but those few of you that
watch this when 10 years from now the
next market crash comes you're going to
sit there and say thank God I paid
attention to this video about how Pat
had a Ford Focus at 28 years old
so stick around to Liberian to get the
PDF of today's notes but let me get
right into it on why today's message is
very important I'm 26 27 years old when
I first started making money at 2122 I
started buying nice cars that go to
Vegas all this other stuff and then all
of a sudden I lost everything I'm 49 000
in debt I'm about to go back into the
military you've heard the story before
then I get into insurance I meet a man
that all he talked about is Pat just
trust me have cash in place if you do
anything with me go set aside cash now
my dad for the longest time always told
me to follow and said always have
savings that nobody else knows about he
said it's healthy for marriage it's
healthy for a man it's healthy for a
business it's healthy for you period
half cash set aside somewhere that I
don't even know about that your wife
doesn't even know about that nobody
knows about because it gives you certain
backing so now today's message is about
business expenses that startups waste
their money on and a lot of people that
are starting a business right now maybe
you're even an independent contractor
salesperson a realtor what insurance
person maybe you start a small business
for yourself with your partner there's a
lot of ways that you're going to be
tempted to waste money I'm going to
share with you what things to look out
for and then the decisions on you to see
what you do with it so let's get right
into it Point number one expensive off
he says you will be tempted to get a
very very sexy office space because you
think the office is going to make you
the money the office is going to make
you nothing let me give you a story
first office lease I signed was in
Granada Hills it was right off the 105
freeway on a meeting I was doing one day
with my sales guys in the middle of a
meeting there was a drive-by shooting
and boom the shot comes from right
behind me there's a hole in the window
on the back to my left and I'm looking
at them like everyone's like oh [ __ ]
what just happened I'll go a little
closer I'm like okay there's something
going on out the cops show up anyways my
first office was a regular office lease
I picked up and I took it from a guy who
was a Countrywide rep making four
hundred thousand dollars a year started
his own Mortgage business boom mortgage
hit say you know the mess they went
through similar to what's going on right
now this was
0.607 I go into the office it's empty I
took it over sublease I saved 20 on the
lease everything else Furniture
everything's about forty thousand
dollars worth of furniture a 25 000
phone system was part of the negotiation
that I got I moved into that office it
was safe it was cheap I could afford it
we started the office space and then
boom it took off within the insurance so
many times you'll be tempted to think oh
if I only have a better office sexier
office or guys are going to be more
excited they're going to be more this
when you're a startup you just want to
make sure to stretch the dollar as much
as possible and the last thing you need
is a sexy office space number two is
over hiring let me tell you what I do
when I hire somebody that's coming on
board if I'm running a startup so let's
just say you're running a startup or
you're a new person you're in sales you
became a broker and you're running an
office or you're running a small little
business that you're running when I'm
doing an interview with somebody that I
bring on board this is a question I used
to not ask early on now I ask this
question every single time just a
question and I say hey John just out of
curiosity uh you ever worked for a
startup before I I never have so
typically when you work is like Fortune
500 Fortune 1000 companies yeah I've
typically worked for an established
company okay let me share with you the
difference between a startup and the
difference between a fortune 1000
company I want you to really think about
whether you want to have this kind of
position or not I said a fortune 1000
you can come in you clock in you leave
and you're typically going to leave on
time if not a little bit even earlier no
one's going to take notice no one's
going to know and say your typical job
expectation is this much you hit it
you're good you'll get your three to
five percent raise every year everything
is good safe no one bothers you right
and that's many people's jobs when they
work for Fortune 1000 company when you
work for a fortune 1 million company or
a 1 billion company which is a startup
obviously understand what I'm saying
here it's a startup and here's how a
startup works it's non-stop it's
constant you're wearing multiple hats
you may have one job two jobs three jobs
you may sit there and have a job
description of what you're doing
sometimes you may do two other jobs
outside of this because it is a startup
so everybody's wearing different hats
one minute I'm wearing this hat the
other minute I'm wearing this at the
other one that I learned is that it's
startup now here's a good Bad and The
Ugly
the ugly is it's constant the good is if
you stick around a startup and you do
something big long term the big money is
made many times by being part of a
startup and you bring value to the
company but for you which do you prefer
do you want more of a fortune 1000 type
of a company where it's safe it's secure
and it's quiet and nobody bothers you do
you want to be part of something we have
the pride that you build something big
together you'd be amazed how many people
just say well you know I really have to
think about this decision you know what
they're saying when they say that that
they don't want to be part of a startup
they want to go to a safe place but you
know how many times when I open openly
talk to people like this you know what
they'll say oh I'm so bored out of my
mind I got a job at a fortune 1000
company I am so bored every day I go to
work like I don't care how much they pay
me my life is boring I need some
excitement in my life I want to come be
part of a startup company phenomenal
then let's go do something together but
I don't have the money to give you an
expense credit card I can't afford to
give you the kind of salary others are
paying you right now because this is how
much money we have that we're working
with we've raised this much money and I
can't overpay you are you okay with that
but in the back end we can do XYZ again
hiring prematurely or over hiring when
you don't have the money nor the luxury
and you need to manage the expectations
up from with the people you're hiring so
they know exactly the kind of situation
they're getting themselves into number
three the Savior consultant avoid these
guys they'll come in and this is what
they'll sound like oh my God this is
your business let me tell you my
background here's what I did for only
fifteen thousand dollars a month with a
six-month contract I'm going to be able
to help your company get into all these
different markets and we're going to
help this company do this this and
you're sitting there saying oh my God
guys I found a savior consultant this
guy's gonna take us to the next level I
know you pay this guy fifteen thousand
dollars for six months nothing happens
first month you ask him in the sixth
week hey man you know I paid you to
fifteen thousand dollars what is really
going on well first month was really
learning and we're kind of going through
our needs analysis the second month is
this really you're gonna start seeing
the impact of what we do for you by
monthly or month four if you've gone
through this you've heard this script
before be careful with these savior
Consultants very careful the way I hire
a new consultant this is how I do it let
me give you the right script hey uh
Johnny I appreciate the fact that you're
an incredible consultant how much do you
believe in what we can do here as a
company oh I fully believe you guys can
pull it off if you guys do the right
things fantastic here's what I'd like to
do with you I'd like to see if you
really believe in what we're doing I
don't have a lot of money to stretch I'd
like to work with you on first month
twenty five hundred dollars and on the
second month you know 3 500 on the
fourth month on the third month forty
five hundred dollars and fifty five
hundred dollars and not a contract but
if you do me good and you hit these
markers that you believe you can do by
the ninth month give you a thirty
thousand dollar bonus if you hit these
markers but I pay you by the ninth month
because you've also helped grow the
company and marketing and this and that
and blah blah blah you'll see how many
times they'll go like this oh oh I ca oh
oh I can't do that they're trying to
tell you that we're never going to do in
the first place or they'll say the
following you know what I understand
what direction you're going I can't
respect the fact that you're a startup
and times are a little bit weird right
now I'm willing to work with you that's
fair because I'm confident what our
team's going to deliver salute let's do
business together but manage
expectations with higher hire
Consultants from day one or else you're
going to be wasting a lot of money
number four lavish employee perks let me
tell you A lot of times people are like
well let me take these guys to a nice
restaurant or let me do this and let me
do that here's what I did okay to build
a relationship and take care of my
employees for the first about a year and
a half when I started my own insurance
company in 2009. every Tuesday night and
every other Sunday I would barbecue for
you but here's what I would do I would
go to local Vallarta okay and I would
buy carne asada okay and I would buy
chicken uh I like chicken uh Thai and I
would marinate it with my own chipotle
sauce and I would put some beer wine and
certain seasoning that I use in certain
middle eastern seasoning and I would
cook for you that chicken would cost me
30 bucks but I would bring it and they
would see me cooking for them just the
fact that I'm spending time cooking for
my guys showed a lot of support to them
they liked it and I'm showing value in
them when you're small and you don't
have a lot of money you don't need to
take people to high-end restaurants to
impress them not at the beginning that
can come later on but not at the
beginning best way to do it maybe you
cook for them to save yourself that
money and establish deeper relationships
number five buying expensive tools look
no matter what you're doing whether it's
going to be a hub spot or you're going
to be tracking your CRM or this or that
there's going to be so many different
tools that you can buy and you will be
tempted to want to buy the highest model
tool that you want to buy for whatever
you're trying to pick up for us for
insurance I had the option to buy
quarter million dollar software versus a
hundred thousand dollars software which
is a 25 000 software you know which one
I picked I went with the twenty five
thousand dollars then we upgraded into
the hundred thousand dollars then we
upgrade into a quarter million dollars
and then eventually we upgrade into the
10 million dollar software that helped
the company become a tech enabled
company but don't be don't sit there and
say oh my God if we only had that
software we'd blow up totally get it you
may not be able to afford the top of the
line software they want but start with
what we have and a lot of times when you
work with a company you can buy the
shell and build up but the biggest
factor is if you know you're going to
make your company win long term
get used to selling your partners of how
valuable of a partner you're going to be
if they buy into your meaning you may
many times I would say John I can't
afford to pay a hundred thousand dollars
but I'd like that software well Pat we
can't afford to give it to you why don't
you start with the 25 000 Auto one I
said I totally understand it I'm quite
to be honest quite honest with you 25
000 is even a lot for me however here's
what I'd like to do with you what's that
how about if we do twenty five thousand
dollars up front and I get the hundred
thousand dollar software but 12 months
from now I give you another twenty five
thousand dollars and then two years from
now I give you another twenty five
thousand dollars and in three years from
now if this thing's going the way it's
going instead of paying you a hundred
thousand dollars by the 30 I pay 125 000
meaning the last check is fifty thousand
dollars and they'll sit there and
they'll say
what is a US given a software anyways
it's not like we need more employees
he's now going to be using more
employees he's not going to you know
what great here you go take the 100 000
software with a three-year contract by
the end of the third year instead of
paying the 25 000 just pay fifty
thousand dollars rather than getting a
hundred thousand dollars we got 125 000
but what did I get in return I got the
hundred thousand dollar software up
front for only twenty five thousand
dollars and I was able to stretch the
dollar and pay 125 over three years so I
saved myself money up front which is
when I need to cash the most because if
you go out of business by the second
year you're not going to have to do the
whole thing the person's taking a risk
I'm buying into knowing you're going to
be there long term but you're also
selling yourself to say I'm going to be
in business and if I am for your loyalty
I'm going to give you an additional
twenty five thousand dollars that's the
point with the conversations you need to
have not necessarily the tools we need
to sell this to people you're going to
be partnering up with number six
business travel look at this point when
I travel I'm generally traveling in a
private jet and Life's a different life
today but here's what most people don't
know about up until until my 10th year
of running an insurance company I flew
coach myself I would fly coach so this
means we have millions of dollars on the
bank
and I'm still flying coach and people
are asking why are you still flying
coach now don't get me wrong when you
fly coach a long time with American
Airlines you eventually get upgraded to
business and first class So eventually
when I became executive Platinum for
flying constantly six months out of the
Year guess what happens you're naturally
going to be upgraded to first class
without having to pay for it but I
wouldn't coach for a long time why you
know because there's different
philosophies here some people say you
should drive you know fly private from
day one because it gets your identity to
realize you belong at the top and first
class is the way to go no problem I sat
there and I said uh you got about 200
flights a year your coach is going to be
450. first class is around 1500 to 2000
200 000 that's going to be thousand
dollar savings times 200 that's 200 000
in savings over the year two hundred
thousand dollars in savings is four
employees at 50 or one c-suite executive
about 200 000 I'm good with it then I
would take the 200 000 and look at the
valuation of a company if I did a two 12
times ebitda 12 times 200 it didn't cost
me two hundred thousand dollars that was
a 2.4 million dollar expensive
evaluation the company so somebody's
it's only 200 000 no no no no no no it's
2.4 million on the back end because of
ebitda so if you can't fly coach and by
the way I'm six four and a half 245
pounds sitting coach on four hour
flights and six hour flight so if I can
do it you can do it as well but the
reality is eventually when you do it
right you got Savings in the Bank last
thing you're going to be thinking about
is coach you'll be first class and
eventually be driving flying private but
for the longest time you don't need to
fly first class coach will save you a
ton of money Point number seven control
enthusiasm let me explain to what I mean
by this if you're part of a company
that's got 3 000 employees how many
negative people you think work for that
company if they got 3 000 employees some
people will say probably none well
that's a lie if they got 3 000 employees
say three percent are negative they
probably have 90 negative employees you
know what these people do well let me
tell you man our vice president and
doesn't care about us look at the CEO
look at the market you know this is not
going to work you know we're going out
of business you know it's just constant
right when you're small when you're big
you can't control negativity you're
going to have negative people working a
lot of different places and they fake it
when they see you well guess what when
you're small and it's only three or five
or ten or 20 or 30 or 40 employees you
can't afford negative employees you have
to spot them early and have a you know
come to Jesus type of a conversation
with them isolate it and let them know
this may not be the company for you the
most nice polite way and let them leave
but the worst thing you can do is just
be like oh it's not a big deal he's okay
oh it's not a big deal it's okay the
longer I've done this many times the
longer you let this person stick around
the more people are going to quit with
them when they quit the sooner you
isolate it and addresses the few people
are going to go negativity cannot be
tolerated when you're a startup At All
by nobody when you're small so listen
the biggest thing about this season is
to think like a founder and I did a
video years ago on the qualities of a
Founder I want to share with you but
before I give you that video I want to
share with you these new hats that just
came out because all I want you to be
thinking about while you're going
through the mess is the fact that future
looks bright these hats just came out
limited edition in the middle it's got
valuetainment all over the place it's
got future looks bright here future
looks bright here and the and the
valuetainment logo on the front you can
buy it in white red or black to sport
this everywhere you go so other
valuetainers when they see you they know
which content you consume if you want to
order these limited edition hats click
here and if you want to watch a video
about the founders mentality click here
to watch 20 qualities of a great founder
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]